hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
eine website entdeckt auf der alle
youtube videos gezeigt werden
die null aufrufe haben hier hinten ist
übrigens keiner weil zwei sind auf
klassenfahrt und ukulele liegt noch
krank im bett
aber wir fangen jetzt an mit dem video
diese website heißt petit tube warum
weiß ich das video was hier uns als erst
angezeigt wird ist das schrecklich wir
können aktualisieren und dann haben wir
als nächstes video hier jetzt
als pressluft sting
sie haben noch mehr von dem
das nächste video was kommt ist
schillers mail
alles klar hero bringt man verzettelt
chinesisch oder ja ohne wohnung
okay das ist auch sehr interessant jetzt
dieses bild hier ja wer wird da nicht
gern boden was das war ein scheiß wer
macht werbung für ein led-licht und
nimmt dann so hofer musik jetzt haben
wir mv
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt mal wieder aktualisiert
was mache ich überhaupt wieder
[Musik]
ich verstecke war wieder so ein tolles
mv movie 3 593 wie blätter filmt
das war's videos aus schüler vorbei hier
geht es um redirection cent prinz
charles buttner ebook pdf
da sehen wir wie das video schon wieder
vorbei ist da man könnte nicht
verlängern konnten 20 sekunden hochladen
dem zu und sieht aus wie mickey mouse
[Musik]
movie 05.02
alles klar hey da bin ich froh ist genau
dieser titel ist jetzt dem 994 für
ottawa mensch freunde wird er immer
kreativer mein gott ich beende an dieser
stelle das video wie reagiere ich glaube
wir haben uns jetzt genug videos
angeschaut die meisten war sehr komisch
und alle hatten 0 aufrufe
ich frage mich gesagt gar nicht warum
wenn euch das video gefallen hat und
eventuell denkt man oh mein gott meinte
jedoch eventuell nochmal auf die website
und schau dir videos an die keine
aufrufe haben dann zeigt mir mit einer
bewertung
dagegen hat ein neues video eine dusche
in echt lass das ist der grund warum ich
jetzt das video beendet